Maria the Newtown documentary how did
you get involved in the film Kim
contacted me when she was in the
community exploring how she was going to
tell this very sensitive story a most
tragic shooting of schoolchildren in
America's history and I was very
interested in the opportunity to take a
look back at a community so devastated
by such a traumatic act of gun violence
to really examine the long terms effect
on a community in aftermath so after the
cameras are gone when a community is
left to pick themselves up and move
forth what happens to the families who
lost children their relationships in the
community the experiences of the
teachers of law enforcement of faith
leadership these were all subjects that
were of great interest to me personally
and that both Kim and I felt were
critical in telling the story of Newtown
for those who feel strongly about gun
control mental illness of a community
dealing with grief what would your
message be to them about seeing Newtown
if they're afraid that it'll affect them
to have lay it it'll be too emotional
although you've done a beautiful job
with the film what would your message be
because they haven't seen it how would
you let them know we were very careful
and sensitive about not telling a story
recounting the tragedy of Newtown that's
that's not the point of the film the
point of the film is really the
experiences of the community in
aftermath of the experience so we
encourage people to see it you know we
don't have the luxury to forget what
happened at the Sandy Hook school and to
the community of Newtown at large it's
part of our history and we hope people
experience a sense of uplift we do think
there's tremendous hope in the message
of community resilience and Newtown is a
tremendous example of that they really
came together on many levels as a
community to move forth with their lives
and you met the parents you met a lot of
the people that were featured in the
film oh yes okay so I have to ask this
question and that is there is a
community of people that feel that Sandy
Hook may have been staged and a hoax and
as insulting as a question as this is I
just have to for the record have you
tell me your opinion or thoughts on
anyone watching that may feel they want
to comment in a negative manner against
the film and what you've done and the
years that you've put into it that's a
yes I mean the idea of you know the
truth their movement and denying the
tragic shooting is it's just nonsense
it's nonsense it's of course insulting
and tremendously hurtful to the families
who lost loved ones to the entire
community of Newtown as it would be in
any case where you know whether it's 911
or other shootings where there are you
know conspiracy theories and it's it's
nonsense it's not worth certainly the
community's time nor our time but it is
certainly unfortunate that they have
reached out in such personal ways to
families who lost loved ones okay this
is not your first film about shootings
can you tell me about your previous film
yes I actually was in Newtown with a
film about Virginia Tech and the
experiences through a student who was
shot five times in the tragic episode
and Colin Goddard is the subject he's a
leading national advocate on gun reform
and we were in the Newtown community
working with advocates and with the
victim community and you know this was
months later when I had an opportunity
to learn what Kim was interested in
developing and you know we were very
like-minded in the approach of telling
the story of community your exact role
in the film you were producer exec
reducer okay producer how did you work
with Kim she was the director what was
your role how was your communication I
believe you
the editing room we were extremely
collaborative you know it's the the
subject is so sensitive that it really
every decision was very careful and in
every way we sought together to honor
the community and the families who had
experienced so much so tremendous amount
of patience was required both in both in
filming and in the editing process and
so you had done a film about Virginia
Tech yes that's right and that was back
in two thousand it was completed in 2011
it was a short documentary shortlisted
that year in 2011 called living for 32
and you know in that film we were more
political and more aggressive about the
issue of gun reform background checks
and exploring legal and illegal
transactions of firearms to make a
political point through the subject
story of overcoming obstacles and and
recovering from such tremendous trauma
but Newtown you know we really felt was
an opportunity to tell the story of a
community months after and years after
the incident and be able to treat
community as character in you know
really transcending failed political
discourse and touching hearts across
America about you know this is what
really happens to a community after such
devastating acts of gun violence so you
knew going in what you did not want the
documentary Newtown to be about you knew
that you wanted to be more about the
community the families can you talk
about that versus a hardcore sort of
political agenda because the movie
doesn't really go there it's definitely
more about the stories of the people
affected yes absolutely you know we
wanted we wanted the store the film to
be as simple and authentic as possible
that word is over used frequently but it
really best describes our strategy and
the honest stories
of what families experienced of a
community members experienced is what we
wanted to share without any any over
direction or leading or comment on part
of the filmmakers really really their
story and what we're finding with
audiences is that it's really touching
people in a very special way because
it's making people feel and think about
the issue in a way that they they
wouldn't necessarily saraly have the
have the ability to do if it was a
harder hitting political and advocacy
presentation right it's definitely much
softer and I like how I believe you did
you use drones in a lot of the film he
asked the drone footage we thought was
very effective in you know bringing the
audience into the community and showing
you know the beauty of in every town USA
Newtown is a very beautiful place yeah
obviously from what you've shown in it
was definitely another character in a
film do you remember being in the
editing room and and certain things that
you decided to change or certain ways
that you wanted to make sure that it did
not become that film that was too overly
politicized that was a very delicate
careful balance and you know it you know
we struggled with presenting two little
advocacy or too much advocacy how much
is too much to tell the emotional
mapping was something that was you know
in the Edit room was a very careful
process our editor Gabriel Rhodes was
just you know tremendously talented and
was able to really help bring the thread
of emotional mapping through the through
the narrative in a way where audiences
can experience and engage through an
intimate relationship with the subject
but without it being too much and too
difficult that was a very careful
balance and you know an example would be
the treatment of the shooter how much
information to provide a
out the shooter and how much not to
disclose that's a very sensitive issue
for victim communities typically they do
not want to honor the shooter by using
their name and media also had cooperated
in an effort called no notoriety and
trying to really keep the identity and
the story of the shooter at a minimum so
we tried to provide as much information
as we could within that balance to
satisfy the viewer as curiosity and and
not too much it seems to be a very new
movement I think as an outcry to us
sensationalizing these shooters and then
hence having these copycat situations
when did that take place this been no
notoriety no notoriety started after
after Newtown and it's you know it's had
slowed momentum and building but I do
see that media is trying to trying to
honor that movement yes I do I think we
all feel responsible in some ways for
the party which is a good thing mm-hmm
advice to other producers i'm working
with a director especially with
something that you want to be very
sensitive about how you were betraying
the film you don't want to make it to
this or to that you know it Sam these
are all unique collaborations and you
know Kim and I were fortunate we really
shared a vision I we never had a moment
where there was disagreement really
about the way in which we were working
with the subjects and I think that's the
most important important component in a
successful collaboration is that you
really have to be on the same page with
the story you want to tell and how you
want to work with your subjects to
really bring about that outcome are you
able to talk about how you receive
funding for the film sure itvs is there
a partner they have been terrifically
supportive we would not have been able
to make the film without them and
transform films is our initial
production partner
and has been very supportive in generous
and the balance of funding we raised
through foundations and organizations
and private funders and how long did
that whole process take or was it
piecemeal it was piecemeal we were
filming all throughout the three years
and we were fortunate that we you know
live in New York and we were able to
travel to new town frequently and
without the expense of you know being on
the other side of the country and that
that was a tremendous a tremendous help
lastly the most powerful thing someone
said to you that's not within the
community after screening I know you've
gone to Sundance and various other
festivals you know I think Jim and I are
very encouraged by the response from
more conservative audiences and often
gun owners in the audience will say
afterward you know I'm going to think
more about how I'm storing my firearms
I'm going to think more about you know
owning assault weapons having them in my
home and I think that's the kind of
discussion that we're hoping will
continue and you know we're hoping that
we can really empower communities to
come together themselves a reflective of
the constituencies represented in the
film teachers law enforcement faith
leadership local community leaders
coming together and having their own
town halls and conversations on the
issue of prevention of gun violence